if you think Rex it was bad here is a
real crisis for you
Britain is soon going to have more
grandparents than grandchildren like
most of Western Europe our fertility
rate is so low it's not even enough to
maintain the current size of our
population better access to
contraception more women in work and
better health care I mean unless we
encourage immigration which is unlikely
we will soon begin to shrink British
women who do have children are
performing just about the most valuable
public service imaginable ensuring the
survival of the nation are we
encouraging these women to have children
no women are becoming mothers in spite
of just about every disincentive Society
could throw at us we millennial women
can expect a hefty wage penalty for
having children opening up a pay gap of
nine percent compared to men by the time
we're 30
fathers may now be eligible for shared
parental leave but it's such a bad deal
that only 2% of them are taking it up
maternity discrimination is rife and the
impact of austerity falls squarely on
the shoulders of mothers if this is
gratitude towards the fundamental public
service mothers play we sure have a
strange way of showing it so yes i think
i think i mentioned paternity leave i'm
glad you did because i think that's one
of the imbalances and perhaps i really
use the word discrimination against
fathers that needs to be addressed and
that work may well help with the gender
pay gap that you referred to because of
course the gender pay gap and the
figures around it I often find aren't as
straightforward as they initially appear
to be there are other structural issues
that yes lead to an inequality in the in
the pay between men and women but unless
the law changes for example it's not
simply a matter of discrimination there
are as in by men in the workplace there
are systemic discriminations in place
legally and paternity leave is one of
them
but moving to moving to the immigration
and population subject yes immigration I
think needs to continue to this country
but it needs to be controlled and
measured I don't in
the whole Merkel style open-door policy
and I think actually the way it's
backfired in Europe with the rise of
far-right populist movements is is a
case in point
as to why we need to I think intricately
tie immigration with integration in all
aspects of that and meanings of that
word including economic and education so
that we can we can actually control and
manage the entire process and the last
thing I'll say is that it's not
necessarily a given that declining birth
rates are a bad thing because globally
in fact immigration cannot be the
solution to this problem especially as
there is a correlation between
increasing or decreasing poverty and
declining birth rates and actually the
world overall is getting less and less
poor and so I think actually we need to
start looking at some technological
solutions for this issue as well on a
global level not not now specifically
and in Britain and it may well be
wonderful for the environment if the
virus on this planet known as the human
species reproduces less actually but we
need to talk about the impact that
having children has on the climate and
on the environment so I completely agree
but my point is I don't disagree with
anything you've said I just don't hear
this debate being had in rationale time
so I'm not trying to make an awkward you
know
okay I'm saying we have an issue here
what is what is that what is that
strategy you're talking about globally
that one of the world's most renowned
population and this says we have to cut
the world population he said he said
this about three years ago and he said
the planet is designed to be able to
look after in terms of resources about
one point five to ten people now we have
seven by 2050 we'll have we'll have nine
billion so he says he's gloomy about our
prospects of looking after the people we
have never mind increasing it but but I
I think I think one of its one is ever
so let's talk about immigration where
this year was the six-year high on
immigration from outside the EU so when
you take away the the commas in the
levers what was left was two hundred and
eighty two thousand people staying in it
these are young people they're going to
be having kids they're going to be
working them not the old people that are
going to have to look after that is
actually amazing so so we don't have to
look we had a hundred and one thousand
from the EU so that's four hundred
thousand our population has increased by
this
which is astonishing we can't afford to
increase it any more than that this
isn't about immigration this is about
the birthrate population you're talking
about saying that when you welcome
immigration that we should continue to
have immigration the shrinking your the
point about the increasing population
globally is a fact there's no question
about India for example is going to
overtake China very soon yes has the
most populous country in the world yes a
Chinese person I'll need a beer because
of China's one-child policy their birth
rate of course has been declining hugely
yeah and if you look at the disparity in
birth rates some of the African
countries at the moment you've got birth
rates of seven six five we're at less
than two and to have to sustain your
population you need a minimum of two
point one there are European countries
now like Cyprus is at one you know you
have countries like South Korea at one
point to Poland is one point three so
you know how and when it comes to
immigration here's a fact the
Conservative Party keeps saying we've
created 3 million jobs in the time we've
been in government well let's hang on
how many European Union citizens are
there over here three and a half million
and what's our unemployment rate four
percent the lowest and living memory
without those three million people from
the European Union we'd have an acute
labor disincentive people haven't just
come back to the UK Africa and you
making money out of beer just calm down
now
back to the UK the equality and human
rights commission found that 75 the
employment rate for women with children
seventy-five percent against ninety-one
percent for men over the twenty years of
a child's life that pay differential
between
a mother and a father is 30% 77% of
working mothers report having been
discriminated against denied promotion
having their salaries caps book and
promotions but they get a cause they are
parents to kid you get tax credits for
kids my mom got nothing when I came
along drive you the Romans were still
here so it wasn't bit different why are
you tax credits not even a drop in the
ocean of the hid you take to your income
your earning prospects and your
opportunities when you have a child out
bristling but the point is when I had a
child I my mentality was this is
something I've chosen and it's a
privilege for me and in a way society is
doing me a favor by letting me and is
only recently I've started to realize
that actually society needs women to
have children this society unless you
want the immigration to replace the
British population you need to stop
having our fertility rate has halved in
the last 40 years do you think the
government should pay for every every
person who has every child let the
government pay for everything we need to
create an environment that allows women
who have children to thrive I come from
one of the smallest communities in the
world as harassed reinforces in India we
are now down to 59 thousand out of 1.3
billion people and the government is
actively it's got adverts that is put
out to the Parsee population please have
more travelling typically as a family
from your community well many of them
don't have children Ozel don't get
married but highly education there is I
mean you know that here's an extreme
example and we might be extinct in years
to come it's it is that that's it's
women's choice that we're gonna change
30 years ago women stayed at home
because that's what they wanted to do
and to bring up their babies these days
women want to do both they want to work
Anna I am all in favor furious I'm not
saying we should be forcing millions
have children I'm saying women are
choosing not to have children can we
please have a conversation about the
reasons why if it's all choice but many
women are saying I've chosen not to have
children or I've chosen to only
reasons because I can't afford it
because I'm talking about facts surveys
that's so bad all you have done with
children